alexa metti dott.sa
[Musica]
arrivando gennari dedotta pensiamo un po
di copyright ha mancato nel canale di
prassi dobbiamo palmare
per evitare copyright arrivare lo
scrivente giampiero
[Musica]
cosa c'è allora poiché scarichi qualcosa
si scarica con il gioco 12 non a fare la
spesa cosa vuoi
vuoi comprare tutto quello che vuoi
pagherò io ma non mi serve niente
meglio
dai fan che ha visto nel candore cagato
nelle mutande
quello con centro la simpatia spettata
al momento a queste per pesare il
pallone
invece fatti andare a buonissimo beffe
madonna successo gol pazzesco il gol
della storia che gioco di squadra io ho
preso la palla l'altra la tira e
l'ultimo toglie quello che la sta
parando cioè che cli pat è la rivista
the c'era incredibile alex a questa è
una grande discoteca
con questa
signora
si no
ecco questa è nelle tue ragazze francesi
i figli insomma più una quota che è
esattamente la sembianza la trota scusa
mi definisci assegnate alla trova
[Musica]
[Risate]
la centrale cesa che ci voleva una
fisica cinque anni sarà così lui a
[Musica]
[Risate]
maria che da parte di
pisticci nato
a tivoli vincenzo quel cui leggiamo caro
come stanno messi la dll cambiato
moglie accendo tutto il il salotto
perché lo posso fare la distanza e poi
ri spengo subito colori spengo subito
[Musica]
mi sveglio
preparo la cena si è affatto così sì ma
lei l'ha poi quando dico
che lo subisco
va bene
[Applauso]
[Musica]
questa è quella della uno stupa quello
che non stai bene la bottiglia d'acqua
salata
ascoltati large
e tutto in un colpo senza che invece la
vecchia si
vadano a votare ma le abbia
la tela della ligue 1 2
cos'è stato entrato a vedere il conto
[Musica]
18 c'è scritto 18 hai sbagliato
regionali sarà legge allora hanno fatto
hanno fatto la divina commedia a mo di
manga ma sai quanto cazzo
una profetica provvedimento è nerissimo
ragazzi e non avete idea accettante dico
c'è tant è che certi poi così di giugno
di giorgio una fortunata ebraica il
comando della il comando ragazzi non è
poi una delle live fino a quando non
cambiate la scena una bella della sua
[Musica]